rebound crowder oh money williams says
mikhail bridges running the floor
shot blocked by antenna once again comes
out of nowhere and throws it off the
backboard
you got to stand the other end
[Music]
[Applause]
just a tremendous in transition chase
down
play great run by bridges
could have easily omani williams says
mikhail bridges running the floor
shot blocked by antenna once again comes
out of nowhere and throws it off the
backboard
yonders down the other end he takes it
home
they have the super sized lineup right
now with fortis
giannis let's head
steam ahead you're in position pick your
spot
and take the hit but the stride and the
explosiveness of giannis
i don't care who you are you're not
going to be able to defend it
phoenix has to get more quick passing
sequences
it's too much hand holding on to the
ball the spin move
the finish giannis does it again
pick your spot and take the hit he spins
[Music]
[Applause]
high speed inside blocked by athena kupo
in over eight minutes here in this
second
an 18-point turnaround as federal gets
inside
giannis tied up finds holiday holiday
trying to get it going he's one for 11.
and fedecupo gets inside layup he banks
it home
putting jonathan into the pick and roll
and paul's finding enough room and
separation
to get off his mid-range jumper and that
in the paint jumper for tedecopo 17
points
here in the first half booker on the
drive
gets inside triple team finds cam
johnson shot clock winding down booker
blocked by antenna
and a 24 second violation wide open dunk
down the other end
tell you giannis has been great
holiday was brilliant in games by one of
the best games of his life
i thought okupo gets the roll count it
and one
the only one that has anything going at
the offensive end
great strength to get that shot up
and in after taking a pretty hard hit
from bridges
his effort to run the floor
giannis tries a three it's good
assistant coaches his dad is an arizona
state was doug collins who coached
through with philadelphia
when he was an all-star with the sixers
calling for it goes against crowder gets
inside banker won't go the rebound back
up and in group strength from the
ability to turn the corner
take a lot of contact pursue the
basketball with that grown man strength
finish back to giannis
[Applause]
backs in leans pulls up jump shot got it
giannis dominating right now
in there with booker again payne played
well in the first half when they were
really struggling offensively
holiday inside antenna combo lays it up
an edge
right out they ran a little stagger back
screen
for giannis and that's a good
job by yanis just stopping right under
the basket and a terrific delivery
booker to paul shot clock at eight
hooker and portis once again
hooker on the drive left handed shot
blocker combo
just clocking two crowner has to put it
up
here come the box fourth projection for
giannis
middleton off the bounce throws it up
bank shot no good
antenna
holiday back on booker and penecopal
picks them up
hookah's blocked by antenna that's five
porters because he didn't get this call
they're asking where's the technical
foul
similar to the one that porter's got
it doesn't look like holiday finds some
room
kicks it out connoisseur middleton
inside nice entry pass
and the slam from the tenukupo
on the offensive end catch finishing
traffic
over everybody feeling the presence
turns out an easy shot odd dunk attempts
and fades away from the rim it's the
presence of giannis the glass
47 points bucks by eight
good ball denial from crowder adelaide
looking
inside of pinocchio puts up the
one-hander shot is good
does it again
[Applause]